Приватний будинок за шість днів - німецька інструкція.
Сонячні панелі, ґрунтовий теплонасос та термоізоляція -
як зробити старий дім ультрасучасним.
Мох на стінах і дзеркало з соцмережами -  найсвіжіші тренди у меблях і декорі з Німеччини.
Друзі, усім привіт! У цій серії пропоную розібратися, як побудувати приватний будинок у Німеччині.
Перший крок - вибір проекту.
Для цього я прибув до виставкового центру FertighausWelt (Фертіґхаусвельт) -
"світ готових будинків" у Кельні.
Це такий собі супермаркет будинків просто неба.
Тут, на території у 20 тисяч квадратних метрів, побудували 24 будинки.
Вартість будівель, представлених тут, від трьохсот тисяч до мільйона євро.
Фрау Клаас - менеджерка виставки готових будинків проводить мене вулицями містечка.
Від архітектурного різноманіття розбігаються очі.
Тут йдеться про те, щоб викликати емоції у потенційних покупців.
Люди в спокійній, затишній обстановці наживо можуть оглянути і відчути будинок.
І одразу встановити емоційний контакт - завдяки знайомству з фірмою, будинком, його запахом.
І зрештою це полегшить їм ухвалення рішення про покупку.
З цією метою у ФРН звели 18 таких виставкових селищ.
У Кельні - одне із найменших, натомість у Мюнхені, наприклад, можна оглянути аж 60 зразків будинків.
Друзі, я фізично не встигну показати вам всі будинки.
Давайте сконцентруємось на двох.
І почнемо, наприклад, з цього з круглими вікнами.
Усередині тепло, затишно і просторо.
Зустрічає експерт з питань будівництва пан Баумайстер. Пропонує каву.
Виявляється, це все-таки не виставковий макет!
У будинку все справжнє і все працює - від кавоварки до каналізації.
Скільки коштує цей дім, і чому така ціна?
На даний момент 590 тисяч євро. Це великий будинок.
Його житлова площа 205 квадратних метрів. Він має два повних поверхи.
Всі будинки на виставці панельно-каркасні, тож збираються, як конструктор.
Цей дім - повністю з дерева. Гарантія від виробника - 100 років, так само, як і на цегляну споруду.
Цей матеріал - целюлоза. Це утеплювач на даху.
Ізоляційна подушка даху тут 25 сантиметрів завтовшки.
На опалення цього енергоефективного дому
нам потрібно лише 55 відстоків енергії, витраченої на такий же звичайний будинок.
Головна ідея таких будинків у тому, що пропонується
повністю готове рішення разом з високотехнологічними системами опалення,
вентиляції, постачання електрики і навіть кухонними приладами та меблями.
Не підходить пропоноване компонування - розроблять індивідуальну архітектуру.
Коли клієнти приходять обирати новий дім, вони мають бути готовими на справжню сповідь:
скільки дітей планують, скільки поколінь їхньої родини житиме під одним дахом ,
бо від цієї інформації залежатимуть параметри майбутнього будинку.
Коли проект будинку обрано і є ділянка під забудову, потрібно отримати ще кілька дозволів.
Наш архітектор складає для замовника заявку на будівництво,
яку подають на затвердження до відомства із нагляду за будівництвом.
Ця установа перевіряє, чи вписується наданий проект в ландшафт,
вулицю і чи враховані всі приписи.
Після цього видають дозвіл на будівництво.
Ну що ж, тепер можна будувати.
Панельно-каркасний будинок доставляють і монтують за 4-6 місяців.
Темпи його будівництва швидші мінімум удвічі, ніж спорудження бетонних і цегляних споруд.
Вантажівки привозять вже сформовані стіни зі вставленими вікнами.
Далі блоки готової теплоізольованої підлоги другого поверху.
Потім зовнішні стіни і перестінки на другий поверх.
Згодом крупні фрагменти теплоізольованого даху, на який лише треба покласти черепицю.
На цьому відео зафіксований період монтажу будинку лише протягом шести днів.
За цей час "коробка" споруди була готова.
Попереду внутрішні роботи і прокладання комунікацій,
які займуть левову частку від загального часу будівництва.
А в цьому будинку з дитячим майданчиком
пропонують найсучасніші та найекологічніші матеріали.
Ну що ж - ходімо всередину!
Добрий день! Мене звати Михайло, Дойче Веллє, Бонн.
Добрий день, я пан Кройцер. Давайте ваше пальто.
Пан Кройцер тягне за дзеркало, і за ним зі стіни виїжджає шафа для одягу.
Ось таке ефективне використання простору.
Досить легко!
Наче і не було там шафи!
Це серце будинку. Кухня, їдальня і вітальня разом.
Дуже часто їх планують спільно - як центральний компонент будинку.
Вітальня сама по собі вже не є такою важливою.
Ця фірма позиціонує себе як виробник екологічно чистих будинків,
які з роками не виділятимуть жодних шкідливих речовин.
Еккарт Кройцер представився саме як експерт з будівельної біології.
Наскільки екологічний будинок, можна побачити на розрізі стіни.
Теплоізоляційний шар формує дерев'яна стружка,
оброблена лише сироваткою й содою для захисту від пожежі і грибків.
Будинок опалюється повітрям завдяки припливно-витяжній вентиляції
з теплообмінником-рекуператором.
Таке я вже бачив у так званих "пасивних" будинках.
Цю стіну можна просто посунути і збільшити гостьову кімнату.
А коли гості поїхали, можна зробити кабінет трохи більшим.
Чудова ідея!
Ще одна проста ідея ефективного використання простору чекала на мене у дитячій кімнаті.
Вперше в житті таке бачу! І що з цим робити.
Зараз покажу.
Навіщо величезні ліжка. Тут собі ліг і відпочиваєш.
Можна дивитися на стелю і мріяти про чудовий екологічний будинок.
Вартість такого екологічного панельно-каркасного будинку - чотириста тисяч євро.
Ще один - набагато дешевший варіант отримати новий дім -
це переробити старий до невпізнаваності, ще й обладнати його усіма "зеленими" технологіями.
Типова німецька історія. Так вчинив наш наступний герой - доктор Томас Кох.
Дім збудований у 1965 році. У нього я інвестував близько ста тисяч євро.
Ці гроші пішли на теплоізоляцію усієї споруди.
Також я їх вклав у встановлення сонячних батарей
для вироблення струму на східній і західній частині даху.
І ще я вклав гроші у встановлення теплового насосу,
який використовує енергію землі ось там. Глибина зонду - 70 метрів.
Від сонячних батарей Томас заряджає і свій електромобіль.
Він жартома прикрутив до свого "Фольксвагена" вихлопну трубу, яку заткнув гумовим бананом.
У підвалі стоїть накопичувач електроенергії від компанії "Тесла".
Зараз такий коштує 5 тисяч євро. Томас каже, що німецькі наразі вдвічі дорожчі.
Вдень аккумулятор заряджається від сонця, а вночі віддає електроенергію будинку.
Надлишок електрики продається у мережу міста.
За рік від подачі електрики у мережу міста я заробляю від тисячі до півтори тисячі євро.
Сьогодні сонячний день, тож Томас на айпеді у додатку демонструє,
скільки він вже виробив електрики зранку.
Дзвінок у двері - прийшов його шкільний товариш Міхаель
похизуватися зі смартфону показниками своєї сонячної електростанції.
Друзі планують загітувати когось із сусідів поставити сонячні батареї,
аби вже втрьох об'єднатися в єдину мережу.
ля переобладнання будинку Томас взяв кредит у банку.
Взагалі-то сонячні батареї, тепловий насос та ізоляційне утеплення належать банку.
Однак завдяки цим технологіям я заощаджую щороку до трьох з половиною тисяч євро,
і ці гроші також ідуть на погашення кредиту.
І останній етап облаштування оселі, звичайно ж, це декор і меблі.
Подивитися на  останні тренди в цій галузі я приїхав
на одну з найбільших виставок меблів у світі - ІММ, що проходить у Кельні.
І що нам пропонують у 2020-му році? Дивіться - мох на стінах!
Якщо на подвір'ї у вашої бабусі завалялися старі двері від сараю,
не поспішайте їх викидати, вони можуть стати дверима для дизайнерської шафи за тисячу євро.
Це справжня штукатурка. Вона мінеральна.
Це перемелений мармур, крейда і травертин.
Все вироблено в Італії. Таку картину ми можемо надрукувати за 24 години.
Також впали мені в око ці мінімалістичні вішаки-лотоси.
Як вони виглядатимуть на стіні вдома, я побачив у віртуальній реальності.
Друзі, а як вам ось така високотехнологічна люстра?
Звичайно, у 2020 році у тренді технології "смарт-будинку".
Це дзеркало у ванній кімнаті, яке одночасно є і величезним тач-скріном під'єднаним до інтернету.
Ну що ж, відтепер соціальні мережі переслідуватимуть вас, навіть коли ви чистите зуби.
Перевіримо перегляди відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину".
Дзеркало-планшет одразу відгукується і завантажує досить швидко.
Друзі, пишіть, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину.
І я обов'язково про це розповім в наступній серії. Побачимось!